could you talk us to the game uh yeah
sure um
i think we were both sort of surprising
each other a little bit in the opening
um what i would say is
i i sacrificed the pawn but eventually i
got very good compensation
with the with the bishop pair then he
tried to
uh he tried to to force force the game
but i
he told me afterwards that he
miscalculated something and i won two
pawns back so i was a pawn up
and still it was not so easy to to win
but uh
i i think um uh maybe um
yeah he didn't probably didn't defend
the best way and then it was fairly easy
okay at the touch of the round you were
awarded the gligeric
award for fair play um what do you think
about the award do you please have
received it
uh yes obviously i'm happy to have
received such an award usually
i'm not like the first person you think
about
in in that regard since i'm somebody who
generally tries to to win at at all
at all costs like not by any bad means
but yeah
i don't i don't think that's the
perception people have of me but
um obviously um it's it's an honor and
i'll try to live up to it
i know you've been in sochi before could
you tell us what you think about the
playing conditions the hotels
what's your experience these days here
so far it's been
it's been lovely so i hope to be here
for a long time
okay well good luck tomorrow and we'll
see you in the future rounds
thank you